Arthur Fleck's biggest joke just might be
the one he pulled on you.
"Ah ha ha ha ha."
Joker director Todd Phillips recently made
a few very interesting comments to the Los
Angeles Times about the final scene of the
movie comments that imply a bizarre truth
about the story being presented.
In case that's not warning enough, be advised
that major spoilers for Joker lie ahead.
Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur is depicted early
and often as having a tenuous grip on reality.
The film eventually lets on that it's not
always clear which events are fantasy and
which are reality not to the audience, and
presumably not to Arthur.
At the end, Arthur is seen with his psychiatrist
in Arkham State Hospital after he has apparently
killed his mother, incited a riot, shot Murray
Franklin on live television, and escaped from
police custody with the help of his clown-masked
followers.
As the shrink attempts to question him, Arthur
simply laughs, telling her that she wouldn't
get the joke.
According to Phillips, it's this particular
laugh that might hold a clue about the true
nature of the story that just unfolded.
He explained,
"That laugh in that scene is really the only
time he laughs genuinely.
There are different laughs in the movie.
There is the laugh from Arthur's affliction
and then there is his fake laugh when he's
trying to be 'one of the people,' which is
my favorite laugh.
But at the end, when he's in the room at Arkham
State Hospital, that's his only genuine laugh
in the movie."
Why is that, exactly?
Well, perhaps because in the end, the joke
is on us, the audience.
Phillips has said that one of the main influences
on his film was The Killing Joke, the acclaimed
1988 graphic novel in which the Joker says
that if he must have a past, he, quote, "[prefers]
it to be multiple choice."
The director made a direct allusion to this
dialogue in suggesting that as many fans have
speculated Arthur Fleck might not necessarily
be who we think he is.
Phillips said,
"There are lots of ways you could look at
this movie.
You could look at it and go, 'This is just
one of his multiple-choice stories.
None of it happened.'
I don't want to say what it is.
But a lot of people I've shown it to have
said, 'Oh, I get it he's just made up a story.
The whole movie is the joke.
It's this thing this guy in Arkham Asylum
concocted.
He might not even be the Joker.'"
Phillips went on to state outright that the
man who will become Batman's nemesis may simply
be in the background somewhere, watching all
of these events play out.
He said,
"Maybe Joaquin's character inspired the Joker.
You don't really know.
His last line in the movie is, 'You wouldn't
get it.'
There's a lot going on in there that's interesting."
Phoenix himself also explained that Joker
can be seen not so much as a straightforward
narrative, but as a series of suggestions.
During his own conversation with the Times,
he said,
"This movie requires a certain amount of participation
from the audience.
It's up to you how you want to interpret it
and experience it.
It's less you being kind of presented with
the facts than you being presented with these
possibilities."
Phillips may have given the whole game away,
however, when he revealed that a face-off
with Batman would never be part of his potential
sequel to Joker, saying,
"We would never do that.
No, no.
We'd just want to see where [Arthur] goes
from there."
"Do you see those two worlds merging together
anytime soon?
… No.
Definitely not."
Taken together with Phillips' previous remarks,
we're left with the compelling possibility
that Arthur isn't really the Joker at least,
not the Joker who goes toe-to-toe with Batman.
His entire rampage might have taken place
entirely in his head; perhaps he told the
story to a fellow Arkham inmate, who told
it to someone else, who passed it along until
it was eventually heard by the man who would
become the true Clown Prince of Crime.
For now we can't say for sure, but don't worry
Phillips told Entertainment Tonight that eventually,
he'll reveal the truth:
"One day I will say what we think and what
we meant when we were writing it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Joker
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.